die deals gibt euro kriegt zwei stellen
falls es überlebe vielleicht gehe ich
auch eine vielleicht nicht und noch
einer und noch einer und noch einer und
noch einer 14 14
okay okay jetzt geht's ab jetzt geht's
ab
es geht sondern bekommt sondern folge
handicap gehen wollen heute wird es
backpfeifen habe die hat bestimmt schon
das video gesehen dass wir mit maximaler
für jeden kill eine stelle
heute spielen wir für jeden kill und für
jeden tod eine stelle und zwar in der
folgenden aufstellung immer wenn ich
sterbe kriege ich eine stelle von robert
von meinem kumpel daneben besitzt und
immer wenn ich ein kind kriegt er eine
stelle von mir so also es wird auf jeden
fall viele schelling in dieser folge
weil gestorben wird immer und vor allen
dingen zwei wms weltgewissen ksg mach
einfach zu heftig wurde niemand
überleben diesen stellen
ich denke hier daran dass an leute das
schiff in krems wo ist dein erster kommt
erstmal kein okay da wusste verschont du
wirst schon besser leben
was sagst du kassierst in diesem video
ja ich denke zweistellige jetzt schon
oder
boah ist das fahrzeug steht anstelle
wegen bist du hast mir einfach
respektieren randalen dass ich den namen
und wenn ich den killer klingt so eine
stelle wenn ich ich und er laut werk
bitte laufe ich weg wird ist ein
spielfeld aber glaubst nicht hinterher
fasst folge hat du hast es seien leute
länger laufen ja aber nicht die ducks
mit eröffnen das ist
die den fussball ihren hallo ich mein
bisschen hinterher laufen
welchen dann direkt erwischt wenn man
die ganze zeit das hat den zweck und
rommel hat die erste stelle in die
kamera und fertig
jetzt gibt's gleich erstmal den kopf
also das ist immer immer immer wenn ich
ein date kriegst du eine wenn ich
gestorben nicht gestorben werde nicht
erwartet da nicht da kommen mag
er wird die man jetzt noch mit ca lieber
nicht wir können nicht sagen
naja fast dahin verdienst übertreibst
normal hätte ich so auseinander nehmen
gleich habe ich auf der haut alles etwas
härter aber okay du kleine [ __ ] ja
ich werde mein charakter skins oder
steaks zurück wir machen kurzen heute
sind es gleich wieder so oder so wieder
leute ohne glos soll das existierst wohl
auch mal
ich habe ich bekommen
oh mein gott oh mein gott ich hab ja
bekommen oh mein gott ich sterbe dann
hab ich doch jetzt wird er hat nämlich
darin gesehen oder wollt ihr mich nicht
gesehen hab ich das gespürt ich habe
gespürt dass die stelle durchaus kräftig
war ein glücksgefühl einen alten
eindeutig märz bitte war noch haushalt
war auf keinen fall auf jeden fall wird
er auf keinen fall
ok ich glaube verrat weiter geradeaus
und der manager
ja ich habe getötet was nicht gesehen
nein ich hab wirklich ich habe ein
getötet die leute ganz überzeugen
die laufen ja dann ich hoffe auf
wirklich schwierig aber ja ok alles
wissen könnte so ein bisschen ausleben
vielen dank an seine zahlungspflicht
diesem moment vorher
die augen zucken weiß jetzt kommt ist
leicht ich glaube ich da nein
jetzt geht der auf mich hier wieder ich
fasse es nicht
nehme ich ihm nicht das können sie ruhig
machen missgeburten hat er die tea
möchte ich fass es nicht
leute ich will der ex thema schreiben
aber okay ich lass das jetzt nicht so
was schlimm du bist hier trennt der
antrag ich fasse es nicht das ist doch
so unfair heute ihr seid einfach so egal
okay okay ich dass man hat ja erst
einmal ja oder ja oder ja oh ja ja ich
spiele so soll das falsche spiel auszug
ist einfach zu gut
der ging der erste ging auch technisch
schon okay was ist widmet ja ich will
halt dann die menge durch die besondere
härte raus härte raus aber macht einfach
kurz
kurz und schmerzhaft
der brennt jetzt
hätte ich jetzt mal bitte um bringen
juni
in diesem fall würde ich sagen
hilf mir sogar danke man wollte er hilft
mir nicht jetzt geht auf mich ich fass
es nicht alltag streifenteam ein und
hört auf mich solche leute hastig arbeit
in der ich ständig angesagt hier
schmunzelt über 40 mit den erfordert
komm her du kommst ja meint wenn ich
dich getötet davon machten stelle für
robert gibt es etwa noch ein und dann
war es das
das macht das nicht dann geht es richtig
los es geht nämlich immer weiter immer
weiter während unseren olli kahn
ja ich habe richtig oder einer sehr gut
es ist langweilig das ist gut das ist
gut das ist gut
wo er denkt denkt und denkt da ist es
nicht aber denkt
das ist ein kollege jetzt kannst du
nicht weglaufen das ganze nicht
weglaufen und er läuft wieder weg ich
fasse es nicht leute wie schlecht kann
man sein
kommt eine neue was für ein asoziales
scheißdreck geschichte
wohin heute je kleiner bastard halbes
herz das gibt es nicht die zeit
er brennt brücke und dreht ab du idiot
ich bin nicht sprinten kommt ja alles
durch härte wieder zu reden
dahinter der zug der zucken zurück die
hat jetzt zwei schläge auf weihnachten
die hört die schwache die wertung
gebracht blödsinn ich hab mich einfach
was hast du einfach sagt noch vor den
spielen mit leid leute wir sind wieder
da dritte runde und für alle die sich
denken basecape machen ist gerade uncut
das heißt die roten ich habe sehr
knappen schwert das ist sehr gut
das ist sehr gut wo war das riecht nach
stellen würde ich das machen was uncut
das heißt natürlich dass jetzt hier
nicht der kasse das gezeigt wird sondern
einfach uncut wie gesagt ja und wenn die
leute einfach so as i spielen wie dieses
team gerade eben abwechselnd dreckig die
einfachen bringen sie unterlaufen die
weg dann weiß ich auch nicht weiter
dann denke ich mir einfach keinen bock
so macht es keinen spaß und keinen namen
wie eine analyse der hecken sowie der
deals gibt euro kriegt immer zwei
stellen weil ich das überlebe
vielleicht gehe ich auch eine vielleicht
nicht so schon wieder zwei schellen ich
fasse es nicht
es ist jetzt so gut oder sind diese
schlecht also ich bin jetzt nicht
besonders gut aber ich kann schon
spielen als sagen wir so oberen zehn
prozent würde ich schon sagen
selbstlos und noch einer und noch einer
und auf 1 8 und nach einer 14 seite vier
stellen für robert volke wolke jetzt
geht's ab jetzt gibt es ab
links rechts links manchmal die
abwechselnd nichts kommt einen außen
kaum hinaus das ist die challenge des
jahrhunderts auf jeden fall
danke an milch was hast du verloren ein
leben nein ich regeneriere ich war 20
schuss fasste ich war schon fast tot
aber jetzt habe ich einfach viel ist
schon gold im moment keine 8 und
aufgehängt sind werte hoch bis dahin
sind da oben stehe für den brustpanzer
an der stelle zu schnell
klar gesehen oder vorne ist da ob der
darunter kommt ich weiß nicht aber ich
kann einfach nicht runter holen ohne
alle fakten wir werden richtig einfache
kämpfer mit der angel herunter holen
könnte
den unfallschaden und dann setze ich
darum zwar mit dem schwert nach
sechstägigen treffens rechts
untergegangen
da geht ok kollege ich hatte einen
kleinen besuch ab da unten in einem
bettchen hab ich dir nicht erwischt
glück gehabt da hätte ich schon gerne
weg gewesen also nicht nicht direkt tot
aber ich hätte mir das auf jeden fall
ins wasser genug dann hat er nicht
weglaufen können dich erwischt so jetzt
gehen wir die man hinterher
wollt ihr versteht ich muss jetzt die
kill soll ich muss dir mal das ist kein
spaß mehr
das ist einfach das echte leben
das echte leben und ich sehr gern für
mich aufnehmen vielleicht wird es
nächstes erfolge vielleicht auch einfach
nur ein xl folgen dann mit mir ist auf
jeden fall immer mindestens ein
er ist gut und ich bin nicht so toll
live ok go [ __ ] [ __ ] auftrag auf wag
da läuft die ganze frontal rein das ist
dem problem egal der hat der focus mich
so hart es gibt ja nicht der gruppe hier
so hast du hast mein herz ein herz ein
herz aber ich kann doch normale gründen
kein problem ich kann einfach nicht mehr
kommt näher
er ist gerade richtig
und wer mich focus leute guckt euch das
an wie hat kann einen menschen focus
helfen einfach die ganze hinterher
ungebremst von tnt robert freut sich
natürlich auch michael sowa seinem rauch
aber okay das kann man schon was wenn
ich richtig arbeit mehr und er wird
garantiert nicht auf eröffnet so ein
gesicht sterbe wo mein gott oh mein gott
wie nervig kann man bitte sein
du willst du nicht die schelle bekomme
du dummer heißt es dort wo pvp mit einer
vier statt wie dumm kann man sein
meine fresse das wegerecht auf das ist
so asozial so was und ich kann darüber
sprechen ich kann jetzt nicht das war's
das was mach ich mal bereit
ja du bist du bist ein idiot kinder bei
mir ausgehen heute fehlte mir das genau
meine katze mein gott wird sich gefallen
lassen lag da schreibt in die kommentare
ob ihr noch eine wiederholung volt
vielleicht noch mal mit robert
vielleicht wird max auf jeden fall war
das richtig gleich das war richtig
lustig und dann würd ich sagen bis zum
nächsten mal drei nachts gut und da